[Music]
one way to enhance eyelashes is to coat
them with mascara early mascaras were
made of petroleum jelly and coal or soap
cake tinted with black dye today's
liquid mascara comes in a tube with an
applicator brush built right into the
cab
mascara formulations vary
the basic ingredients are wax water
pigment and binders
additional ingredients produce features
such as water resistance
[Music]
every formulation is comprised of an oil
soluble phase and a water soluble phase
to prepare this mascaras oil phase a
technician combines four types of wax
carnauba from a Brazilian palm tree
candle Leah from a plant that grows in
parts of Mexico and Texas beeswax and
glyceryl stearate an emulsifier which
helps ingredients blend well
next comes vitamin E which conditions
lashes and gives the mascara a smooth
texture after that is a chemical
compound called pala MALDI mm which
makes the mascara water-resistant the
technician heats this oil phase of the
formulation once the waxes begin melting
blends the ingredients
[Music]
wax is a thickener this calculated
combination of four different waxes
produces a semi-liquid gel that coats
lashes with a shiny film
the technician now prepares the
water-soluble phase of the formulation
separately first heating up cold water
then adding an emulsifier this will bind
the water and oil phases when they're
combined later on without an emulsifier
oil and water-soluble x' would naturally
separate the next ingredient is a
cosmetic grade iron oxide pigment the
color is black because she's making
black mascara
[Music]
she blends the mixture until the color
is uniform
[Music]
then she adds te a this organic compound
balances the mascaras pH level so that
it isn't too acidic or alkaline
next she adds a cosmetic powder to make
the mascara silky and a chemical to
provide additional water resistance
finally she completes the formulation by
adding the oil phase to this water phase
heating the mixture while blending
prevents the waxes from solidifying
before packaging the factories chemist
runs quality control tests
using a viscometer to measure thickness
he makes sure the mascara isn't runny or
gooey he also tests the pH level if the
sample meets specifications the lab
gives the go-ahead to package the
mascara and a worker pours the batch
into a filling machine
[Music]
the machine continuously mixes the
mascara and keeps it hot so that it
remains liquid otherwise the mascara
would begin to cool and jellify and clog
the filling nozzle
[Music]
a mascara bottle typically contains
about two ounces of mascara as it cools
in the bottle it transforms into a semi
liquid gel she seals the bottle by
pressing in a plunger style plastic
stopper
[Music]
the stopper has a hole in the middle for
inserting the brush applicator that's
built into the bottles cap
[Music]
the lip of the stopper hole is designed
to wipe off excess mascara as you pull
the brush out of the bottle this helps
prevent the mascara from clumping
this manufacturer fills small orders
manually like this one for a private
label brand it's automated production
line is reserved for large orders
regardless of quantity clients specify
the characteristics they won in their
brand of mascara such as lengthening or
water resistance and the manufacturer
tailors the formulation accordingly
you